all right well jenn pasaki will be
moving to msnbc in a few months no
conflict of interest there at all i mean
she's the still right now the press
secretary
and she's supposed to field questions
from the media
and they're supposed to be
an antagonistic relationship
between
the the press secretary the white house
and the media because they're supposed
to be holding you accountable
democracy dies in darkness right
washington post um
but james hockey now is in the position
of uh she's you know doing these press
conferences with people who are she's
they're going to be her co-workers in a
couple of months and and um
so but no not no conflict of interest
there and now she seems to really be
sort of preparing for that gig here she
is crying
crying
over the thought of kids not being
drugged and castrated just to reiterate
that she's crying
over the thought of kids not being
drugged and castrated
idea of you know the very idea
that a 14 year old girl
might not have her breasts chopped off
the very idea that a 12 year old boy
might not be chemically castrated and
sterilized for life
reduces her to tears
watch this
the political
games and harsh and cruel
attempts at laws or laws that we're
seeing in some states like florida that
is not a reflection of the country
moving to oppose lgbtq plus communities
that is not what we see in data that is
not factual
and that is not where things stand this
is a political wedge issue and an
attempt to win a culture war and they're
doing that in a way that is harsh and
cruel uh to a community of kids
especially i'm i'm like going to get
them i'm going to get emotional about
these issues because it's just it's
horrible but uh but you know it's it's
like kids who are bullied and this is
like all these leaders are taking steps
to hurt them and hurt their lives and
hurt their families and you look at some
of these laws in these states and it is
going after parents who are in loving
relationships who have kids it's
completely outrageous um but it is it is
a wedge issue sorry i and this is an
issue that makes me completely crazy um
but it is an issue that um is a
political wedge issue it is not a
reflection of where the country is
uh
you see this is this is what we're up
against why
just playing defense is is not an option
when this is what you're dealing with
actually reduced to tears it's it's not
just that she's
arguing for and trying to justify the
chemical castration and and mutilation
and butchering of kids
which of course will be bad enough
but that she's
emotional about the idea that we would
protect kids from that
just think about it and she's yeah
there's there's some acting involved in
the crying but it's not all acting
i think we'd make a mistake to just
assume that that's all performance that
might be a part of it
but then you're i think you're you're
kind of doing her some favors in a way
because no she really is these people
really are that deranged
to not only be in favor of chopping the
breasts off of 14 year old girls but to
be
emotional about it
she says we have to protect kids from
bullying well
i agree with that
and there are no greater bullies right
now
who are targeting kids
than the
vultures in the pharmaceutical industry
and the medical industry
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated